we have more Falcon and the Winter
Soldier leaks as everybody knows
production and filming for the series
has begun and of course with filming
having started that means we're going to
get more leaks and more information
about this series and today we have a
leak about a new awesome character being
introduced to the MCU and the series
Battlestar so I'll break it down in this
video and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button like I said today we
have a scoop about Lamarr Hoskins aka
Battlestar now we know that John Walker
is going to be introduced in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier series as US
agent no surprise here as eventually he
does go on to become Captain America in
the comics and as it turns out he's
bringing another comic book buddy along
with him for his MCU debut Battlestar so
this report comes from Charles Murphy
and he has confirmed that Battlestar
will be making his MCU debut in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series and
this is seemingly confirmed thanks to
some leaked photos that we have thanks
to Instagram user just BG for Stacy in
Georgia where of course they are filming
the series right now a local grocery
store has been transformed into a flower
shop and as you can see from these
leaked photos this flower shop is called
Hoskins family flowers now as I
mentioned before battle stars true name
is Lamar Hoskins so this is clearly
going to be his family's flower shop now
this could be a front for something
because I'll talk about who Battlestar
truly is in just a second but it could
also be a legitimate flower shop in
which Hoskins works at and eventually US
agent John Walker comes and recruits him
now for those of you who don't know
Battlestar has an interesting role in
the comics with US agent John Walker now
when John Walker was introduced in 1986
in the comics he was introduced as the
super Patriot and with his introduction
Hoskins was introduced as well as a
fellow military member who served
alongside John Walker
they were also introduced with two
former military members as well calling
themselves the bold urban commandos or
known as the Bucky's now battle star and
the Bucky's hold a very specific purpose
for u.s. agent the buggy's actually
staged attacks which provide John Walker
the opportunity to save the day this of
course is to make him look good so he
can gain favour in the government's eyes
and in
America's eyes and it works his
popularity Rises and eventually the
government makes him the new Captain
America but he doesn't forget about his
buddy Hoskins Hoskins ends up becoming
the new government sponsored Bucky so
there's a new Captain America and
there's a new Bucky now in the comics
Bucky eventually changes his name to
Battlestar because he believes that
Bucky is a little racist
but Battlestar gets his powers the same
way John Walker gets his powers from the
power broker so right now it seems like
we're going to get a slight adaptation
of this comic story and there seems to
be a little bit of a theme here at the
end of Avengers in game we know that
Steve Rogers give Sam Wilson the shield
therefore Sam is supposed to become the
new Captain America however we know that
that's not going to happen at first John
Walker is going to be the first new
Captain America now we assume and
basically know that eventually Falcon
will become the next Captain America but
John Walker is going to take that title
first and now it seems like Bucky
doesn't even really get to keep his
title as well it looks like they're
going to bring in Lamarr Hoskins as
battle star first to take Bucky's place
as well and there's a pretty logical
explanation for this Sam and Bucky were
once wanted heck in Avengers infinity
war Thunderbolt Ross told Rhodey to
arrest Sam
now they're both heroes now after the
events of Avengers in game since they
help save the universe but since they
were wanted fugitives the government may
find it just a little bit hard to
announce them as the new Captain America
and new Captain America's sidekick so
that's probably why they won't be taking
on these new Mantle's at first and real
quick I just want to thank dashlane
again for making my youtube life so much
easier
their app and extension stores all of my
passwords and credit cards securely and
auto fills everything when I'm trying to
pay for something or log in to my
different YouTube channels or different
social media sites like Twitter
Instagram Facebook etc if this sounds
like it would make your life easier and
you would like to support the channel be
sure to click the link in the
description down below to get the app
for free on one device and get a 30-day
free trial of dashlane premium no credit
card at all required so while Sam Wilson
should be the new Captain America and
Bucky should just be Bucky or the Winter
Soldier it seems like the government is
going to bring in replacements for them
at least at first so for the time being
it looks like we're going to have a new
Captain America
John Walker and a new Bucky Lamar
Hoskins aka Battlestar and it does seem
like they're going to play pretty
important roles it doesn't seem like
they're going to be going away anytime
soon when the series starts and although
US agent and Battlestar aren't really
the villains I'm sure they're going to
go up against the true Falcon in the
Winter Soldier
so we'll probably get some pretty cool
scenes when that happens so let me know
if you are excited about this in the
comments down below also don't forget
about my Xbox one and ps4 giveaway all
you have to do to enter is subscribed
with the notifications turned on and
like this video for your chance to enter
also if you'd like a chance to win an
Infinity Gauntlet be sure to click the
link down below as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof